- [Interviewer] All
right so I call you Hop.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] All right Hop,
where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- Harrisburg Mississippi.
- [Interviewer] Harrisburg.
And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents growing up?
- Yeah, both my parents,
my mother was a beautician.
My father was construction worker.
He had moved us out here from
Mississippi in the early 50s.
We had had problems with
the Klu Klux clan back
in Mississippi.
Coming on our yard, attempting to kill me.
So my mother wanted her children
and herself out of Mississippi.
So we came out here and created
his own construction company
and spent a lifetime hustling and working,
saving his money.
He lived well.
He did real good in his profession.
And my mother as a beautician did well.
- [Interviewer] And how would
you describe your childhood?
- Wonderful, wonderful.
My mother spoiled me
as I was the only boy.
So she's for me to death.
She dressed me in tailor
made suits and diamonds
and kept me in Cadillac's.
And the women that she...
That was her clients,
babied me and spoiled me
and some of them sex me as a child
and created the me that I am today.
- [Interviewer] So it's
not really in your family
but you were introduced to it.
- Yes when I was about 16 years old,
I had a child by a girl
that was younger than me.
A couple of years younger than me.
And I decided to leave home.
When I left home, I went to
her parents home to visit her,
let her know I was leaving, growing up.
And she told me that
if I gave her 90 days,
she'd put me in Cadillac's
and knits and stuff.
And she did, she did.
At the time, I didn't
know anything about heroin
and pimping, but she gave it to me.
She groomed me and taught
me how to talk to women
and how to deal with women.
- [Interviewer] This is a common story
that I've heard from a lot
of the gentlemen that you do.
- I don't know any player
who women didn't turn out.
Those guys that claim that
they got it naturally,
was born with the gift
and stuff like that were frauds to me.
Every time that I saw anyone
that was really good at pimping,
they were good because the women told them
how to be good at pimping.
- [Interviewer] What is it about,
because these are all
African-American women.
What is it about the culture that,
that makes this a thing?
I mean, what is it about the...
- Well, when I was a younger cat,
it was people were poor.
Black people were poor,
they didn't have anything.
The only thing that black women could do
to really enhance the man that they love
was the hoe, selling
bodies and stuff like that.
Or to become hostesses for males.
I've had aray of different
women of all races in my life.
I just showed you a
photograph of a lady with me
and she was Indian and she became one
of the best con plan females
in the history of America.
- [Interviewer] But what is
it about the black culture
that makes it the woman's job to
build up the man?
- Well in our culture,
the woman was always there
during slavery times up until the '70s.
Women was always there
to protect the black man
from slave master and from slavery
or mill mat bad and male
treatment of slaves.
And so she took on the responsibility.
When modern times came, she took
over the responsibility to take care
of her man and her children.
- You think that's where it stems from?
- It does for a matter of fact.
- [Interviewer] if
you're from Mississippi,
you would know, right?
- Yes. Yeah. For sure.
- [Interviewer] That's interesting.
Cause that's the one part of the puzzle
that really doesn't seem to make sense.
Like the women are
always grooming the men,
teaching them how to do this,
so that they can give
them all their money.
- Right. Well, it becomes a
unity thing among our people
and my girls and I we all a team
and we respect it like that.
And I'm there because I'm that
male element that they need.
- [Interviewer] To provide guidance?
- It becomes essential.
But when they have the
male element in their life.
- [Interviewer] What are
you providing to them?
- I provide security.
I provide information and
intelligence and knowledge.
They know how to talk to a man,
how to treat a man, how to please a man.
And they can't get that
from another female
until that female become groomed as a hoe.
- [Interviewer] But
you're not forcing them?
You're not oppressing them?
You're not doing anything--
- That's outside of pimping.
- In real life, in real life,
I don't know about the fantasy
books that people read.
- [Interviewer] Well there's
many different styles
I've learned.
- But women tend to,
that's really in the game,
choose the man that they wanna be with
and not be forced.
Those guys out in the
street forcing women,
kidnapping women, making them do things,
is the reason that the feds
have this slavery thing.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] The human trafficking?
- Yeah human trafficking
- [Interviewer] All the new laws.
- There's more of a problem
to play real players
and real holes because they don't
wanna be trapped up in that phase,
that kind of time for a profession,
that's really a lovers profession.
- [Interviewer] The way
the game is played today
is an altered version of what you've...
- Yes it is crazy. It's insanity.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, because now it seems
like the women are totally
been being taken advantage of.
- Right Hugh Hefner dated for years.
For decades, Hugh
Hefner, Playboy magazine.
He did it for years and years and years,
throughout his sources
and hostesses for me
you know what I'm saying?
And it was all nonviolent and
wasn't nobody forced to do it.
And the women loved him for it.
And as for that companionship,
that male companionship
and the same thing goes
on in the communities,
in the streets
with players and hookers.
They want that
companionship, that security,
that protection and that love.
Because a lot of girls men don't have it.
You know, being abused
by fathers and uncles
and other men until the point
that they are destroyed,
emotionally destroyed,
psychologically destroyed.
So they need a man to
put them back together.
So you take her and you make a buck naked
and then we cloth her.
You throw in the backroom in her.
- [Interviewer] Right. But
some of them younger girls
and younger pimps I think are
playing the game differently
where the guys are luring them in
with telling the girls
stories they wanna hear.
And then once they kind
of get them hooked,
then they turn into...
- [Interviewer] I've been in
all the federal prison pimping.
Just recently, in 2013, I was
in the MDC jail down here,
the federal jail with guys
whom had trapped girls
and kidnapped girls and put them down
and forced them to do
things sexually for money.
And that's a totally different perspective
about the pimping than I had ever known.
It was sickening to me.
It was way out nasty.
He might well have been a child molester.
- [Interviewer] Right?
Cause the way you play it,
it's not something disrespect.
- It's a gift.
And it's a mental game.
- [Interviewer] But like mind
control has been mentioned.
- Yes it's a mental game,
you got to know how to sex your mind.
- [Interviewer] So that
is part of your game?
- Yeah and then you put her back together.
You can't take someone who
is so psychologically damaged
and do anything with
them until you strip them
and then refortify them with
strength and intelligence
and make them ladies.
- [Interviewer] Are you
building their self worth?
- Their self worth and all that, all that.
- [Interviewer] And after...
- They got they opinion of themselves
and the psychologic thing
or their opinions of men.
Once they find out that they're beautiful,
that they are intelligent,
that they're worth something,
then they become a value to you too.
- [Interviewer] And these
women are free to leave
at any point ever?
- Whenever they get ready.
Whenever they get ready,
they're not forced to be with me.
- [Interviewer] And they
leave with a nice nest egg
of money.
- Yeah I've had them to leave
and then come back at a later date.
Love me more.
- [Interviewer] Interesting.
How old are you?
- I'm 74.
- [Interviewer] You're 74.
- Yeah. My first prostitute,
she's passing away now,
she's in a coma.
But all of these years,
since the '60s till now,
she's always been there for me.
- [Interviewer] And so you
would have, how many girls
in your stable stable?
- Up to eight.
- [Interviewer] And you'd
have sex with all eight or?
- Yes.
- You would?
- [Interviewer] And the girls
would all understand this
and it's all just accepted?
- No problem.
They would bring them to me.
Other girls who loved
them and love me too.
All the years that I've been in his life,
that's been like that for me.
It's a artwork.
If you know how to do it
and you know how to love women and
how they convince women to
love you back out of respect.
You get that.
- [Interviewer] So have
you been in love before?
- Yes I have a wife now.
I love her.
- [Interviewer] You're married?
- Yes she's 32 and she's with me.
- [Interviewer] She understand what you do
and how you do it and all that?
- She with me 100%.
We live in Las Vegas.
I miss down here for a
family reunion thing,
but we live in Vegas.
We live West side, Northwest Las Vegas,
in a gated community.
We live well.
- [Interviewer] And your girls
work the streets, casinos.
- Casinos, the streets and hotels.
- [Interviewer] Internet as well?
- Some do interned work
those who know how to.
- [Interviewer] And what
if the girl gets arrested
or something.
- I get him, I go get them.
- [Interviewer] You help them out.
- Immediately go get them. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And the
girls are all cool with you.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] None of them are being...
- Nobody.
- [Interviewer] regulated
or forced into it.
- None.
My name rings a bell among them.
They know where they're
gonna be treated well.
And they respect that out of them.
- [Interviewer] So they bring you 100%
of the money each night.
- 100% and I take care of the family.
- [Interviewer] And you do what for them?
- I take care of the family,
provide housing departments
and clothes and whatever
else that they require
to the point of even, you know
those who are still on their
period, they got that coming.
So it's a family situation.
Nobody's without the things
that they required to
survive from day to day.
- [Interviewer] So the way
you play it, you're claiming
it's an offshoot of...
The way the slavery relationships
existed many years ago.
- Yeah. It was not...
It's not slavery.
It's not.
- [Interviewer] No, no, no.
But what you're saying is the
way African-Americans existed
because of slavery is kind of,
this is an offshoot of that relationship.
- Yes okay. I accept that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah no I'm not
saying you're doing slavery.
I'm saying...
- No. no, no.
- [Interviewer] No I'm
saying it's a derivative
of the way men and women
interacted back then
because the women who
were protecting the men.
- That's right.
- [Interviewer] Because the men...
- And it's still that
way today in the sense
that financially they
are there to make sure
that we all got enough financing
to take care of ourselves.
In terms of physical
protection, then I'm there.
- [Interviewer] But if you
have eight women or 10 women
that leaves about seven
or eight guys there
without women out there in the world
- The women out number men.
They need someone to be with them.
That's what make polygamy work.
Is there's more women
than men in the world.
- [Interviewer] Yeah but now they don't
have numbers eight to one.
- About 10 to one, I think,
throughout the world.
Don't you think?
- [Interviewer] 10 times
more women than men?
- Yes. Something like that.
Something like that.
- [Interviewer] I'm not
sure about that statistic,
but I'll let you slide on that for now.
- You let me slide.
Well let's do this check it out.
I don't know specifically the percentage
but there are more women
in the world than men.
- [Interviewer] That might be true.
- That's from way back in biblical times.
And that's why Abraham was able to
have all the women that he had.
- [Interviewer] I suspect
that the successful pimps
are high status males.
- Without a doubt.
- [Interviewer] So you have
the ability to attract eight
or 10 girls.
- Without a problem.
- [Interviewer] Whereas some guys are...
- Sometimes even more.
- [Interviewer] Yeah and
some guys just don't have
the ability to do that.
And they get the scraps.
- Don't have the knowledge to do it.
I see cats every day that are
forcing themselves on women,
don't know how to talk to women.
Asking for something that
they can't ask for it
because they don't know
how to approach it.
You see what I'm saying?
When you got guys like myself
who don't have a problem
with the amount of women
that he can incorporate into his life,
then you see the difference
between the average cat
that doesn't have nods and a cat like me
whom all his lifetime has had nothing,
but his life has been surrounded by women.
- [Interviewer] Have you
ever had to get physical
with a girl?
- Nope.
- Never.
- I refuse, when I get to
a point when a woman does
that to me to make me feel
like that I leave her alone.
She's not worth it.
- [Interviewer] And there's
many different styles
to this subculture.
The other girl pimps, there's the young...
I call them tennis shoe pimps.
There's basically gang members
that are just figuring out
the money off these women.
- You're right.
And those are the ones
that feds are to getting
hold to today with human trafficking
and that human trafficking starts
with 20 years in prison in federal prison.
I just left in 2018 with people like that.
Had that kind of time.
You know what I mean?
Five or six different chases
for five or six different women.
- [Interviewer] Is that
upsetting to you to see
that the game has kind
of turned into that?
- Yes it is.
It's giving it a black eye.
- [Interviewer] Because it's
so drastically different
from where...
From the stories that like
Fillmore slim will tell
or yourself, right.
Which is more of a gentlemanly thing.
And the women are coming
to you and offering you
this wonderful life.
- That's a gentleman's game.
- [Interviewer] To the young
guys that are just like,
deceiving and tricking and abusing.
- Abusing them.
But really, and that's as
bad I've seen up there.
I've seen women situate cases
where the women were burnt,
kidnapped, hailed and
route locked in rooms.
For me, the MTA apartments,
given drugs, turn out on drugs
and all that sort of stuff
in order to get them to work.
And that's not good because
you got to constantly be
on them, aware of where they at,
what they're doing, you know what?
I'm not going to pimp like that.
You know what I mean?
Girls get up and they know
it about five o'clock,
you get up and get prepared
themselves to go to work.
I ain't got to tell them.
They know what the schedule is.
When guys doing like that,
they're just making it look bad
on guys who really professionally pimping.
- [Interviewer] And your girls will make
how much money per tonight?
- Well according to
what they doing tonight.
So some nights are different than others.
I've had a 2,500 one girl,
but that's those nights
that they have enough dates
and they pretty much know the dates
because they're scheduled dates.
They've been dealing
with for months or years.
It's just a difference.
- [Interviewer] Is there a quarter?
- Yeah normally 1500 to a
thousand to $1,500 a night.
But according to where Vegas
is different than Los Angeles.
You know what I mean?
You got a lot of males
that come to Vegas purely
for the girls.
And it's a girls city.
So in a situation like that
they can get more money
and a run over the evening
than they could here in Los Angeles.
- [Interviewer] And you
know, I've heard many pimps
and girls tell me stories about how...
Finessing the guy out of his Rolex watch
or his money out of his wallet
or something like that is
a big part of the game.
- Yes if you know how to do it.
I don't allow them to steal.
I don't want somebody's watch
or somebody's ID and
all that kind of crap.
The wallet, don't bring that to my house.
They steal phone because it's dangerous.
It can track the phone and
all that kind of stuff.
And you end up with bigger problem
because it turns hoeing into a robbery,
hoeing into a burglary, to a felony.
- [Interviewer] And you've been
doing this for many decades?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Tell
many crazy story or two
that you've seen.
Tell me a crazy story that
you've seen over the years.
- Well, I saw little mama abused.
In most situations.
- [Interviewer] The girl
that I've interviewed.
- Yeah you interviewed.
In most situation, her lifetime.
I knew her mom's like I said,
she had been an abuse girl
and manless, you know,
and men would get her
because she was so timid and so small.
She 47 years old,
she still acts like
she's a teenager child.
And I've seen her just used up really.
And that was bad.
At those times was about
as bad as I've seen it
because I hated the people
that was doing it to her.
I hated it to see it.
I like I say, I saw her two days ago.
Me and my girl, we was
coming down pig at a 109th
and she was walking down the
street and I caught her walk.
I said, that love walk like little mama.
And she said that it was a little mama.
So I stopped her.
I pulled over and turned around
and went back and stopped her.
And she said she was broke.
And I gave her $50 and sent her way.
Told her she needed me to call me
because I had just heard
it maybe a week before that
some men had her on a
period in Avalon raping her
and abusing her.
And I asked her about it.
I told some people that told
me that this had happened.
Then was it true.
And she denied that it had
happened, but I know her.
It happens to her all the time.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
happens to a lot of girls.
- With little mama,
I think is a little bit more than normal.
- [Interviewer] It's such
a dangerous lifestyle
for the girls or it's
turned into that at least.
I mean maybe when you started that kind
of stuff was not happening
but it certainly is happening now.
Almost every girl has a story
of some kind of kidnapping,
raping something.
- Right. Back in the day,
they didn't have what
a couple of hoes strolls in his city.
Downtown here, they had Western and Adams
and the main one was the most potent one.
was Broadway and sloshing
around the five-four ballroom
where the black musicians
used to entertain,
James Browns and Tina
Turner the night now.
From there from 54th, from
Broadway to 59th in Broadway
they called the Broadway
and slow scenario.
And the streets was known
in plain pimping players
would all look out for each other's hoes..
You know what I mean?
If you wasn't there on the stroll
the next pimp would make sure
that your girl got where
she was going and back.
You know what I mean?
And we would take down
license plate numbers
and stuff like that.
That's the trick.
We got your license plate number.
So if you hurt her, you harm her.
We gonna see you.
And that sort of thing.
Nowadays it's not like that.
Girls are being butchered.
I knew the guy that was
killing all the prostitutes
from years back.
The Grim weeper, I used
to live on the same street
with this dude on 80th and in Western.
And he just went out to
the street and killed.
He didn't kill girls out to neighborhood.
It cause his house stayed with
prostitutes that smoke crack
and he wasn't killing him,
but he'd go somewhere else
and he had this fetish
idea about killing women
but I knew that cat.
- [Interviewer] The glim sleeper?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah it seems
to me the gentlemanly way
of playing this game is gone.
And now it's thug...
- Yes. A lot of pimps graduated.
You know what I mean?
Or upgraded their game.
They stopped hoeing, stop
letting hoes hoe for them
and start committing fraud, you know
sending them in banks and stuff like that.
And so that protected them, you know.
And most of the females in my life
from the past are now playing con
or instead of selling their
bodies are playing con
or either doing bank fraud.
- [Interviewer] Have you done prison time?
- Well, yeah.
- [Interviewer] What for?
- Bank fraud, pimping and
pondering, white slavery,
the man act federal.
- [Interviewer] And what's
the most important thing
you've learned in all your
years of doing this...
- To stay a gentleman.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry.
- To stay or remain a gentleman.
To treat the game with respect
because it will treat
you with respect back.
To have a good name on the streets.
It's important.
Cats live a whole lifetime, you know
awfully reputation and they
don't want to endanger.
It's like having a million
dollars in the bank for security.
If your security is your name,
your reputation among the
girls and the guys in the game.
It's important.
If you don't have a good
reputation then you nothing
out in the streets. Nothing.
My name rings bells all over
the country for good game.
You know what I mean?
Good game.
And people say, man you solid.
When you get a name that not solid
that people don't see you as being solid
then you're nothing.
You're going to go in and cut
your throat, commit suicide.
If you truly dedicated to this life
and you're not carrying it.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Well, Hop thank you so much
for sharing your story
and giving us a little bit of your wisdom.
- Thank you for having me.
- [Interviewer] Very
nice. Thank you very much.